foreign
[Music]
welcome back to Harbor unboxed now
recently I put together a 41 game
Benchmark comparing the GeForce RTX 4060
and Radeon RX 7600 and I found that on
average the Radeon GPU was seven percent
slower at 1080P and although it did cost
10 less I ended up handing the GeForce
GPU the win for its Superior feature set
so I did fully acknowledge that neither
GPU was particularly impressive and in
the current market probably should be
avoided and instead I pointed Gamers
towards previous generation products
such as the 6700 XT which for roughly
the same money does offer more
performance and more vram but there is
also cheaper options and today we're
going to look at one of them but before
we do today's sponsor spot is brought to
you by us hover unboxed store so
powerunbox.com if you go there you can
check out our merch of only available to
us-based viewers at this point in time
so I apologies to everyone else but we
are working on making it a bit more
Global anyway we have it it depends if
you guys have watched the Q and A's
you'll know that most of answers start
with it depends and it became a bit of a
bit of a joke a bit of a meme for the Q
a series so we've got a Tim and Steve
8-bit it depends hoodie available in a
few different colors and of course sizes
and stuff so if you're interested in
that check it out and there will be more
cool funny meme merch to come but anyway
that's it get back to the video
okay so it's been a long time coming and
while not entirely my fault the updated
Intel Arc benchmarks they are well
overdue now previously I had planned to
include the arc a750 and a770 in our RTX
4060 and RX 7600 Day One reviews but due
to compatibility issues with some of the
games that I was testing with they would
drop from the results due to a lack of
time to solve those problems if they
were solvable with the current driver
and since then Intel has released a
number of key driver updates that do
solve those issues while also improving
performance in a few other games so I
thought it was about time that I tried a
40 plus game Benchmark with an arc GPU
and it wasn't all that smooth sailing I
have to say but we were able to get
there in the end and I'll talk a bit
about that towards the end of the video
for now let's touch on a few pricing
discrepancies I am well aware that the
RTX 4060 and RX 7600 currently cost
significantly more than the a750 with
the Radeon GPU at 270 dollars and the
GeForce GPU at 300 while the a750 that
can be had for as little as 200 us
though it is more commonly found up
around 220 us still it is much cheaper
even at that price as that's a 27
discount when compared to the RTX 4060
so in terms of specifications the a750
features the same 8 gigabytes of gddr6
memory as you'll find on the RX 7600 and
rtx4060 but it uses a much wider 256 bit
memory bus allowing for a bandwidth of
512 gigabytes per second and that's a
massive 88 increase over the much more
expensive RTX 4060 the a750 also uses
the full pcie 4.0 times 16 interface
whereas both the AMD and Nvidia gpus are
limited to half of the pcie bandwidth on
paper the a750 it does look pretty good
especially for 220 us though of course
in the past we have found that it is
only able to roughly match Parts like
the RX 6600 and RTX 3060 so how will it
stack up against this newer generation
of AMD and Nvidia gpus well let's go
find out for testing we're using our
ryzen 7 7800x 3D test system with 32
gigabytes of ddr5 6000cl30 memory using
the latest display drivers in total I've
tested 41 games with 54 different
configurations but we're only going to
look at the individual results for a
dozen of them before checking out the
big breakdown graphs but please note all
graphs will be made available to float
plan and patreon members okay let's go
take a look at what we've got
first up we have fortnite and here we're
using the DirectX 11 mode so no fancy
Ray tracing or anything like that is
enabled and the a750 does really well
here edging out the RX 7600 to come in
at 17 sold in the RTX 4060 at 1080P and
just seven percent slower at 1440p where
the additional memory bandwidth is
really coming in handy
now enabling Ray tracing with the
highest quality preset results in pretty
poor performance overall but here the
a750 is now not that much faster than
the 7600 and is able to roughly match
the 4060 at 1440p moving on to Star Wars
Jedi Survivor the a750 was good for
60fps at 1080p using the Epic quality
preset making it 15 slower than the RTX
4060 which is impressive given it is up
to 33 cheaper then at 1440p the margin
is heavily reduced to just nine percent
and again we see that the a750 is able
to benefit from all of that extra memory
bandwidth unfortunately enabling Ray
tracing and Star Wars Jedi Survivor does
the a750 and in this example
it's slower than even the RX 7600 at
1080p we're seeing a 36 performance
deficit to the RTX 4060 while the Intel
GPU was 30 slower at 1440p Hitman 3 is
one of the oldest games that we're
currently testing with and the a750 does
really well in this established title
basically matching the RTX 4060 at 1080P
and that meant it was seven percent
faster at 1440p so competitive
performance overall and very impressive
for around 200 U.S
and it's even better with Ray tracing
enabled we're looking at RTX 4060 light
performance at 1080p with 13 greater
performance seen at 1440p or 33 greater
performance when compared to the RX 7600
so again very good results here in
Hitman with Ray tracing enabled
now we see that the a750 it's a lot less
impressive in f123 despite delivering
what I would call very solid performance
overall certainly very playable
performance but here it is 40 slower
than the RTX 4060 at 1080p though it was
able to claw back quite a bit of that
margin at 1440p or it's now 28 slower
still a big margin though but probably
about what you'd expect from a GPU that
does cost around 100 US less
enabling Ray tracing doesn't really help
the a750 in its battle with the next-gen
gpus from AMD Nvidia as here it's 27
slower at 1080p still despite low frame
rates overall that margin was reduced to
just 16 at 1440p
now moving on to Resident Evil 4 we find
a very competitive performance from both
the a750 using the prioritized Graphics
quality preset here it was just 17
slower than the RTX 4060 and
impressively that margin was eliminated
at 1440p with both gpus rendering 65 FPS
on average
then with Ray tracing enabled using the
maximum quality preset we find some
truly impressive results for the a750 as
it blew away the RX 7600 and even beat
the RTX 4060 delivering 14 more
performance at 1080P and 10 more at
1440p
next up we have the Callisto protocol
and again the a750 looks good here with
85 FPS on average at 1080p making it
just 16 slower than the RTX 4060 and we
saw that it was just 13 slower at 1440p
the ray tracing performance in the
Callisto protocol isn't as impressive
though it's competitive at 1080p
especially with the Radeon GPU and a 21
loss to the much more expensive RTX 4060
it's not that bad
we're also looking at strong performance
from the a750 and Far Cry 6 97 FPS at
1080p meant it was 18 slower than the
RTX 4060 and 8 slower than the RX 7600
then at 1440p the margins are reduced
and now the a750 is just 13 slower than
the GeForce GPU and then if we enable
Road tracing we see that the a750 is 16
slower at 1080P and just seven percent
slower at 1440p so again given the price
I think those are some pretty good
results
the a750 was good for 95 FPS at 1080P
and Forza Horizon 5 which is obviously
good performance overall though that did
make it 23 slower than the RTX 4060 and
21 slower than the RX 7600 unfortunately
enabling Road tracing with the extreme
preset did seem to the a750 a
bit certainly more than you'd expect
based on the ultra quality results at
1080p the frame rate dropped to 73 FPS
and that meant it was 31 slower than the
4060 but just 13 slower than the RX 7600
the margins did come down quite
significantly at 1440p as here the a750
was 22 slower than the RTX 4060 and just
seven percent slower than the RX 7600
moving on we fight the a750 was good for
76 FPS and cyberpunk 2077 using the high
quality preset and that's a great result
given that that made it just seven
percent slower than the RTX 4060 then at
1440p it was actually slightly faster
than the RTX 4060 and right there with
the RX 7600 with 52 FPS
the ray tracing performance though it's
a bit of a blowout the a750 like other
gpus tested here just can't come close
to delivering playable performance under
these test conditions but still it was
much better than the RX 7600
the second last game that we're going to
look at the individual results for is
Marvel's Spider-Man remastered and here
the a750 produced 110 FPS at 1080p which
is a good result overall though that did
make it 26 slower than the RTX 4060
which is quite a significant margin but
as is often the case the margin was
greatly reduced at 1440p as here the
a750 was just 17 slower with 85 FPS
versus 102 FPS
and then enabling Ray tracing doesn't
really change too much here at 1080p the
a750 is still 22 slower so similar to
what we saw previously without rtfx
enabled and then at 1440p we are once
again seeing that the a750 trails the
RTX 4060 by a 16 margin though this time
the Intel GPU was able to match the RX
has to be said that Hogwarts Legacy is
not a great title for the a750 there are
a few titles where it does struggle The
Last of Us Part One being another clear
example and we'll look at the margins
for that game in the big comparison
graphs in a moment
here we see though that a 25 loss to the
RTX 4060 eternity P it's not exactly
terrible I suppose but a 33 loss to the
RX 7600 that's probably what jumps out
here to be fair though the a750 did reel
in the competition at 1440p coming in 20
slower than the RTX 4060 though it was
still 31 slower than the RX 7600
the big issue though for the a750 and
Hogwarts Legacy can be seen when trying
to enable Ray tracing as here it ends up
being 43 slower than the RTX 4060 at
1080P and 27 slower than the RX 7600 and
the 1440p data well it's just no better
Okay so we've just had a look at a dozen
of the 40 plus games tested with and
without Ray tracing enabled and now it's
time to see how these gpus compared
across all of the games tested so let's
go do that starting with the 1080p data
so here we are the 1080p results
covering all 54 test configurations and
overall the a750 was 19 slower than the
RTX 4060 which isn't bad given it's at
least 27 cheaper there are some standout
bad results though for Intel and The
Last of Us Part One is a glaring example
along with Hogwarts Legacy using Road
tracing and then f123 still there are
some highly positive examples as well
such as Resident Evil 4 Hitman 3 and
control
now even if we remove the ray tracing
results the a750 is still just 19 slower
than the RTX 4060 and I say just 19
because it is at least 27 cheaper so
taking that into account I think the
performance that we're seeing here is
quite good and then if we look at just
the ray tracing results we set the a750
is still 18 slower so scaling relative
to the RTX 4060 is much the same with or
without rtfx enabled
now the a750 and it's greater memory
bandwidth resulted in much more
impressive performance at the 1440p
resolution at least relative to the RTX
4060 is here it was just 13 slower on
average Again The Last of Us Part One
and Hogwarts Legacy were problematic but
those tunnels aside I think performance
overall was typically very good
and the rasterization only results again
show similar margins and here it's
really only The Last of Us Part One that
saw problematic results for the a750
then when looking at just the ray
tracing data we find that at 1440p the
a750 was on average 14 slower than the
RTX 4060 which is another solid result
for Intel so there you have it almost
one year in the while and I think it's
safe to say that Intel's Arc gpus
they've come a long way upon release the
arc series it was plagued with
compatibility and stability problems and
on top of that the value just wasn't
there losing out in terms of value to
comparable Radeon gpus
today the arc situation is much improved
and while not perfect Intel has proven
they're willing to invest the time and
money to make it work now during my
testing I did run into a few issues for
example Halo often crashes when loading
the campaign and once I did manage to
load the game I was faced with texture
corruption issues but Intel is aware of
this problem and claims that a future
driver update will fix the problem
another issue we're seeing in control in
order to enable Ray tracing I had to use
a command in Steam that forced the game
to load using the DirectX 12 mode really
not a big deal but also not an issue
when using an AMD or Nvidia GPU
and then there's the performance issues
The Last of Us Part One was unplayable
using the ultra quality preset at 1080P
and this shouldn't be the case also
performance in Hogwarts Legacy wasn't as
good as it should have been and while
f123 ran quite well overall I'm sure
there's still some optimization work to
be done in that title overall though Arc
is now in a much better place and
providing you not heavily playing one of
those titles with a few issues still The
Experience should be very good now when
it comes to Value it's difficult to nail
down a part like the a750 as there's a
lot of things to consider but if we base
our performance measurements on all 54
test configurations just looked at I'd
say that coming in 19 slower than the
RTX 4060 while costing 27 to 33 percent
less is very good that also made it 12
slower than the RX 7600 at a 19 26
savings so again pretty good there as
well and of course a more direct
competitor right now would be the Radeon
RX 6600 and sadly I haven't had a chance
to dedicate days of my time or almost a
week in fact to run the RX 6600 through
these same 54 tests but based on the
data we do have the a750 should now be
around six to seven percent faster than
the RX 6600 on average and with both
priced around 200 to 220 us that does
make the a750 a better value and the
advantage of the a750 is superior Ray
tracing performance for whatever that's
worth at this performance tier while the
advantage of the RX 6600 is just more
reliable performance so better
compatibility with much more mature
drivers so given all of that it is
difficult to recommend the a750 over the
RX 6600 or a 250 us RX 6650xt and even
the savings when compared to the RX 7600
might be a bit difficult to justify
still the a750 it's certainly a viable
option at the current 200 to 220 asking
price and that is a fair discount from
the original 290 us MSRP
anyway let me know what you think about
the a750 at its current price and what
it offers and have you actually
purchased an a750 or maybe even an a770
I'd love to hear about your personal
experiences with it and that is going to
do it for this video don't forget to
check out our merch at the uh Harbor and
box store harborumbbox.com you can get
where you can give this hoodie or some
other meme merch and if you'd also like
to become a hardware unboxing member
then check out float playing patreon you
can sign up to either one of those and
it'll get access to stuff like what do
we have we have an exclusive Discord
server for members only we do a monthly
live stream Tim and I get together
answer your questions live and talk
about whatever's been going on that
month
behind the scenes content Journal stuff
a lot of cool things there so check that
out if you're interested but if not
that's perfectly fine and I would like
to thank you for watching this video I'm
your host Dave see you next time
[Music]